un colloque a été organisé aux mureaux
sur les services de protection de
l'enfance
dix mille trois cents enfants et jeunes
majeurs sont suivies par ses services
dans les yvelines et dans les
hauts-de-seine
le budget est conséquent 370 millions
d'euros chaque année mais la politique
menée semble inefficace
pour autant si nous hébergeons ses
enfants si nous les logeons nous ne leur
donnons pas toutes leurs chances pour
pouvoir retrouver une place dans la
société
si l'aide matérielle et financière doit
perdurer les questions liées à la
psychologie au traumatisme de l'enfant
doivent être prises en compte
comment gérer le traumatisme parce
qu'autrement on voit bien que chez
beaucoup on les retrouve un peu plus
loin sont les retrouve dans la rue on
les retrouve souvent au chômage
et d'ailleurs le chômage peut les amener
dans la rue et on a vu à l'occasion des
récents procès des islamistes que un
certain nombre d'entre eux étaient
passés par des structures d'être social
en france donc c'est bien la
démonstration que les traumatismes n'ont
pas été traités parmi les projets la
création d'un institut
interdépartementale du psig le
traumatisme de l'enfant la création de
cet institut psychotraumatiques de
l'enfant est quelque chose de très
important puisque on sait bien que
plutôt on prendra en charge les
traumatismes de l'enfant mieux on pourra
les soigner et venir en aide et prendre
en charge ces enfants
cet institut se veut donc être un outil
de traitement mais aussi de recherche
100 millions d'euros y seront consacrés
sur dix ans